samedi jeff marche depuis le 7 janvier
membre de la solidarité courent les rues
il veut sensibiliser à la pauvreté et
dénoncer la misère pour toutes les
exactions que les migrants et les
réfugiés subissent après tout ce qu'ils
ont vécu on continue de les traiter
comme des moins que rien et c'est
absolument pas normal
et pour pour dire que plus personne
quel que soit nationalité carte
d'identité ou pas ne doit dormir à la
rue et ne doit mourir à la rue on a en
permanence à peu près six marcheurs sur
chaque étape avec des roulements et des
gens qui qui nous rejoignent au fur et à
mesure sur les sur les étapes
ils sont partis dans j'ai un peu plus de
300 km de marche une douzaine d'étapes
et le lancement d'une pétition et oui
voilà aussi on fait déjà participé par
une petite signature ça c'est cool c'est
déjà un bon début
et après à ménager du temps qu'on va
faire bonne figure et aller sur place
soit c'est déjà un bon début
normalement oui aucun problème le suivre
à pied énormément obligé pas que
j'aurais pas le courage à faire autant
de kilomètres
leur périple a pris fin le 21 janvier
plus de 200 personnes se sont retrouvées
sur le champ de mars à paris
la pétition a recueilli près de 800
signatures